in the film's prologue the Magi Warrior
Artist Bay explains that anaksu namun
was the pharaoh's mistress and it was
forbidden for any other man to touch her
to make this point anaksu namun wore
very little clothes and was instead
covered in an elaborate body paint
design that ran over most of her body
when her secret lover the high priest
emotep touched her in a moment of
passion he smeared the paint it's that
smudge that reveals her betrayal to the
Pharaoh the smudged body paint is a
clever shorthand that lets the audience
in on the moment without over explaining
it it certainly let him know that
someone touched his mistress but it
seems like anaksu namun could have just
as easily smeared the paint by bumping
into a wall or laying down for a nap
plus waking up and applying all of that
paint every day must have been the worst
morning routine ever no wonder a naksu
namun went looking for another man
check out Looper for other details you
missed in The Mummy